um I think that there's two ways to look
at this right one is hey I am in the
market and I don't have that feedback
loop but also if you look around the
room nobody else has that feedback loop
as well right and so it's almost like
you know this could be a disadvantage or
if I understand that everyone's kind of
got the same disadvantage can I actually
use this to my advantage which I think
you guys have done very well yeah that's
right and I think also one of the things
you'll find as well as that there's
really no formula for being a good or
greater successful investor I think that
what one needs to do is understand their
self and then understand the market
opportunity and try and bring those you
know in line right like we were saying
earlier you know they're a short seller
is a great example right you look at the
chart of the S&P 500 over the last you
know 50 80 years etc tough market to be
short right it basically looks like a 45
degree line more or less up into the
right some short sellers have been you
know successful others have never but
you're wrong clearly much more often
than you're right
right and so it's not a good or bad
thing but some people have the stomach
to be wrong nine times out of ten you
know 99 times out of 100 and have that
one pay for the rest early stage
ventures is a little bit like that as
well right there's like the power law
right great fun portfolios are not a lot
of you know 5 X fun is not a lot of
moderate exits
you know it's typically one driver or
two compensating for many many losses
right and that can be very effective but
not for everyone and only if you have
the stomach to be wrong for long periods
of time right there are other people who
might need more consistent positive
feedback it might be like a streaky
shooter in basketball right you know if
you get hot and you feel good you're
playing from the front foot right or if
you come out of the gate and attract me
first versus last you know there are
openers and closers etc and so I think
one of the things in the market is know
you want to study you want to study all
the external things that you can but you
also really want to keep a close eye on
yourself and understand where your own
personal strengths and weaknesses lie
and then you want to construct an
investment story
which plays to those strengths and
weaknesses right if you just hate losing
money if it throws you off all the time
right then
hey investing is a difficult job for you
but B you should be taking you know
short stop losses right you should be in
incentives that have a high probability
of winning but perhaps a low magnitude
of the winnings when you win right if
you're kind of somebody who's built with
more of a homerun mentality right if
that works for you
and not because you want it to work for
you because it actually works for you
you know they need to take a different
approach right so I think that you know
one of the things we try to do and every
time we bring on a new hire we're
bringing in a whole new psychology to
the firm and so one of the interesting
things about you know coal running your
own firm is you're also trying to bring
people who have a different perspective
than you right have different strengths
weaknesses you know versus yourself and
you know create a portfolio and a
platform where you know everybody's
doing as much of what they're great at
as possible and as little whether or not